I've been at the Letterman Show since
1991 and that's 18 years and i would say
during that time the comedic sensibility
of the show has changed I want to say
half a dozen times because dave has
gotten older but the average age of the
average writer has stayed the same so
they bring in their sensibilities and
what they think is funny and they try
and interject it in the show and so the
show's comedic sensibility changes and
it's it's all valid and we don't write
anything and think oh I need to write
this joke to appeal to the crucial male
18 to 34 demographic we don't think like
that at least i don't i just think
what's the funniest take that that i can
do and sometimes i think that things
have passed me by just because I'm older
and the people watching are our younger
sometimes I think that but funny is
funny is funny and if you show somebody
a Marx Brothers movie who's never seen
one I think that they'll think it's
funny and I don't think that they're
going to ask why isn't Groucho naked you
know I want to see grouchos deal
late night has really changed in the
last I think in the last three decades
let's say I think that first of all
there's there's more variety and there's
more competition you know before 1982
there was Johnny and Johnny Carson and
people that he knocked off so all of
late night was just was Carson and it
was a monologue it was some sort of body
broad comedy aimed at people over 30
clearly um and white people over and
white men over over 30 and so that was
it and then Dave it came along in 1982
and NBC gave Dave Letterman one
directive whatever you do we want it not
to be The Tonight Show so we want a
three joke monologue not a 25 joke
monologue we want you know we just don't
want it to look like The Tonight Show so
given that go ahead it was very
free-flowing it was irony based and it
was the old producer Bob Morton used to
say Late Night with David Letterman it's
celebrated failure it was not slick it
was very anarchistic and so that was so
then that comes along then you have Dave
moving to CBS 11 30 and you have this
situation with Jay where you had one
show that was a host driven which is
Dave and and material driven more i
would say more concept driven and then
he had another show which is jay who was
just
essentially just a comic who got his own
show and its monologue and guests and a
little more traditional and then you had
the 1230 shows with Conan and all of a
sudden they were David started this with
going after younger audiences I mean
people always say I started watching
Dave in college and so there was a real
market out there and then like I
mentioned before late night became this
very lucrative industry for the
network's very cheap to produce very and
of course once commercialism once people
start making money it's going to tend to
get a water down and it's not going to
be as it's not going to be as fearless
because there's a lot of people that
depend their livelihoods depend on your
success so it's not just kids screwing
around anymore and then what happened in
I would say the late 90s is that the
other the cable emerged as a late-night
force with the daily show and colbert
and it was much more topical not that
the Letterman Show we always took care
of what was in the news and so did Jay
but it became more of the the topical
stuff it became more topical and more
issue oriented and and I think we've
certainly gone in that direction at the
Late Show and so that's the evolution of
that now I think that if i was to
predict and believe me I'm always wrong
so put your money elsewhere I think
we're going to reach a critical mass
with the the topicality thing and people
getting their news because I think it's
going to get a little too partisan and I
think that late night shows are going to
be put in
a situation that they shouldn't be put
in you know unbeknownst to them and I
think it's probably going to go back to
a little sillier and a little less
celebrity-driven and and and kind of
easier to take unless fo serious you
look at a guy like Craig Ferguson and
watch what he's doing he nobody is doing
what he's doing and and I think he'll I
think he will emerge because he is silly
it's all him you know uh you know the
guests don't really have to say anything
he's going to take care of it and I
think that I think that that's where
we're going
I don't think that Johnny ever dreamed
that he would influence an election you
know he he never talked about Watergate
when Watergate was going on talk about
it after the fact but you know Tina Fey
had as much to do with the last election
as as Dave did with the situation with
McCain as The Daily Show does so you
know look where that is i mean that's
where we are where these shows and and
and and and none of these shows set out
to influence elections but that's what
happens there they're right in the
popular culture and you know i never
bought all those studies and surveys
about people getting their news from
late night television I and I still
don't but i think that people turn to
late night television to see what the
point of view is on the news i think
they know going in I don't think we're
in the education business here's the
deal with society people fall in love
with the idea of things rather than the
reality of things and that holds true
for late night you know it's it's so
much more provocative and sexier to say
that people are watching our show in
getting their news from Dave Letterman
and let me tell you as somebody that
writes monologue jokes and somebody that
knows Dave I tell them you we find that
very funny